it's great to be joined today by James
Whitman who's the Ford Foundation
professor of comparative and foreign law
at Yale Law School also author of this
book
Hitler's American model it's so great to
have you on and let's start with the
book many people have some understanding
of what we sort of know colloquially as
Nazi race law but they may not know all
of the different components that were
either inspirations or otherwise sources
for that race law so let's start at the
very beginning Nazi race law refers to
what in the context of World War two
well it's important to distinguish
between the early years of the Nazi
regime and what came later what we
remember most these days is of course
inevitably the Holocaust but in the
early 1930s after Hitler first seized
power the Holocaust was really not yet
on the horizon there was no notion among
the Nazis that they would engage in in
mass killing which seemed if nothing
else in practical the early version of
Nazism that's embodied in the notorious
Nuremberg Laws of 1935 involves a
different program was aim was to force
the Jews to flee from Germany what it
involved in particular was two measures
first the creation of a new form of
second-class citizenship for Jews and
second the introduced introduction of
measures intended to forbid interracial
marriage between Jews and what the Nazis
called re ins that is their concept of
Germans and also extramarital sex and
talk to us a little bit about some of
the some of the specifics of how those
laws were written some of the details
maybe that people have not heard of
observe the logistics of this uh well as
the laws in the sense were written very
hurriedly and reaction to a diplomatic
conflict on with the United States in
September of 1935 but they've been in
preparation for quite a long time and in
particular the preparation involved a
great deal of careful study of American
models that for a very straightforward
reason really the United States was the
leader in innovative racist lawmaking in
the early 1930s something that Europeans
particularly Europeans on the right wing
had been very conscious of for quite a
long time
the Nazis knew it too Hitler himself in
prefer to the United States as the one
state that had made progress for the
creation of a healthy racist order so
let's let's dig into that because for
most people who learned you know us
history history of World War two in
school the sort of general understanding
is hey the United States when when we
got into World War two we were against
Hitler we were against the Nazis there
would be no such connection or
inspiration in terms of anything that
Nazis did at any point from the United
States so talk to us about what
specifically may have been an
inspiration in terms of the Nuremberg
Laws that was going on in the United
States
well it's quite true that when the
United States entered World War two it
was on terms of great hostility with
Nazi Germany there's no doubt about that
but the hostility really didn't clearly
introduce itself into relations between
the two countries until the late 1930s
really not until 1937 or so in the early
1930s the Nazis still saw a great deal
to admire in the United States among
other things they admired Franklin
Roosevelt and his style of government
shocking as it is to hear it now but
beyond that the Nazis saw a great deal
in the American race order to admire
this was of course the era of Jim Crow a
Jim Crow legislation as everybody knows
targeted african-americans in the south
but there was more to it than that there
was a great deal of national and
nationwide race-based legislation in the
United States to the United States was
in particular famous for its immigration
legislation which was designed to
guarantee be continuing dominance of the
white anglo-saxon Protestants who were
thought of as the as the true and
natural inhabitants of the United States
the United States also they created
something of great interest to the Nazis
forms of second-class citizenship not
even so much for african-americans
because their citizenship was at least
in theory guaranteed by the Fourteenth
Amendment but for members of other races
such as Filipinos Puerto Ricans and to
some extent Native Americans this is
something American lawyers had done a
spirit of great creativity but the Nazis
often found admirable how do we know I
mean you talked about this in the book
how do we know that that Nazis were
looking to what was happening in the
United States what what historical
record do we have
well they said so themselves the most
dramatic evidence comes from the
stenographic transcript of a meeting
held in the summer of 1934 to plan the
Nuremberg Laws that meeting a particular
turned on the question of how to
introduce what the United States is
called anti-miscegenation legislation
that is law banning interracial marriage
and the participants in that meeting
engaged in very close examination of
state statutes from all over the United
States in fact at the beginning of the
meeting the Minister of Justice
presented a memorandum on American law
which has been put together by the
Justice Ministry precisely for the
purposes of this discussion beyond that
there was a great deal of published
literature describing not always in
admiring terms but very often with
admiring terms American law among the
published literature may be the most
dramatic example comes from volume
called the National Socialists handbook
for law and legislation from 1934 1935
that described the United States of the
country that had achieved the
fundamental recognition of the need for
race-based law a fundamental recognition
that it was Nazi Germany's calling to
bring to full fruition so the the big
picture of this I'm sure will come sort
of as a shock or surprise to many in our
audience who were not aware of this as I
mostly wasn't before I read your book
generally speaking was there any kind of
effort to suppress knowledge about the
inspiration that not the Nuremberg Laws
drew from what was going on in the
United States or is it has it been
because of lack of interest that it's
not been discussed nearly as much as we
might imagine or why do you think that
this understanding is missing for many
people I don't know if there's been any
deliberate suppression in the United
States and it's not exactly if there has
been in Germany either but the topic is
one that it's very difficult for Germans
to discuss in order to do this work one
has to be willing to plow through an
awful lot of technical German law
and for the most part naturally Germans
who would do that but in Germany these
days it's very very difficult for
serious scholars to make a career if
they're willing to say anything that
would suggest in any way diminishing the
moral responsibility of Germany for the
crimes of the Nazis and in that sense
it's entirely understandable that
Germans have not investigated these
these issues
I suppose you kind of have to be an
American in order to be willing to do it
let's take a pause right there we've
been speaking with James Whitman who's
the Ford Foundation professor of
comparative and foreign law at Yale Law
School this is his book Hitler's
American model we are going to pick it
up with him there on tomorrow's program